construit en 1932 le moulin de saint cyr
doit prochainement être rachetées et
détruit pour cause son esthétique ainsi
que sa proximité avec le parc du château
de versailles qu'un seul mur et ses
parts dans le cas de cette préparation
des jus tout le monde s'est rendu compte
que ce bout là devait disparaître
ah bon parce que c'est vraiment le lieu
où il y aura des problèmes d'éducation
et donc on est quelque chose qui soit
qui correspond plus à la beauté du parc
du château
ce projet s'inscrit dans la rénovation
de l'allée royale de villepreux où se
trouve le site de l'étoile royale qui
accueillera en 2024 les épreuves
équestres des jeux olympiques de paris
le bâtiment devait d'abord être
transformé en tient lieu mais c'est
finalement un parking de 150 places qui
sera construit c'est assez paradoxal est
que c'est les élus ils sont mobilisés
trois mille ans la situation et quand
c'est l'état lui-même
une fois que j'utilisais lice mobilisés
a mis la barre très haut j'allais
détruire le bâtiment
il estime x un bâtiment neuf et
l'objectif est de dégager et mettre en
valeur ce passage vers le parc du
château afin que promeneurs et joggeurs
puissent s'y rendre en se garant à
proximité
je crois que les habitants ils sont très
contents d'avoir une perspective ouverte
sur le château et que on crée une
pression supplémentaire
je tourne en montée cette entrée elle
est naturelle il faut les exploiter
parmi les autres plan de valorisation de
cet espace la future ligne 13 du tramway
qui reliera saint germain en laye à
sentir un arrêt devant cette entrée du
parc du château est prévue